well there's a number of ways I guess
I'll start out by talking about the way
that we do it that maybe is a little bit
distinctive among business schools the I
think the signature element of our our
school is our MBA program a particular
compared to others is what we call
action based learning so right now for
example all of our 425 first year MBA
students would not be found in Ann Arbor
they will be scattered around the globe
in about 90 teams working on real-world
problems so what we've done to try to
differentiate us our students and really
provide value-added was probably about
10 years ago slightly before I got to
the school we instituted what we called
this map project which is called multi
disciplinary action projects so we've
since built that up and really invested
in it as our point of differentiation
and so we source about 120 projects a
year from from around the world of three
different types we have corporate ones
which would be like with a fortune 500
company entrepreneurial and nonprofit
ones and then after the students take
the required curriculum from august
through the end of februari in march and
april the only thing they do is one of
these projects so right now we have
saying we have all of our first year MBA
is out working on these real-world
projects around the globe so about half
of them are outside the United States
and our thinking on that has been that
clearly business schools have to be
close to the world of practice and you
can get there a couple ways one is one
way is to try to import the business
world into your school via for example
case studies are as we have done
recreating a trading floor that you'd
find here in New York or another finance
center in the world and bringing that
into the school the other way is you can
take your students and your faculty and
put them out in the world of practice
and so that's what we've done it really
should try to distinguish our program
and it it's it's a
a really great way of educating students
and also a great way for us as the
school to see what the interesting
problems are out there in the world
because in the course of having these
students do these projects we probably
visit about 150 companies a year to ask
them if we could do a project with them
of something that's really salient for
them today so we get a pretty good sense
of sort of what's on people's minds by
the kinds of things they would like our
students to work on so i think that
injection of our students and our
faculty out into the world of practice
on a full-time basis for two months of
the of The Karate required curriculum in
the first year and we're doing this over
and over and over and so we're able to
actually get a look at some some
problems in detail so for example a few
years back CK Prahalad who's on our
faculty decided he really wanted to take
a look at the issue of canned businesses
profitably served the poor of the world
and so the basis for his getting look at
that question was to do 10 map projects
with companies organism OC nonprofit
organizations around the world and that
really was the raw data which became his
book the fortune at the bottom of the
pyramid so I think in the way that some
other schools would try to have their
connection with the world to practice be
by bringing in outside speakers and
making sure the faculty will bring
current events into the classroom we do
all that the same as any of the leading
business schools would but I think this
is what's really kind of been
distinctive for us and has really been
terrific in terms of a way for us to see
what the interesting problems are in the
world for our faculty to be out there
and also for our students really to be
solving real-world problems and all
their ambiguity and uncertainty that I
think has really been a hallmark of the
school
well I think it is necessary to have a
global presence in some way or another
and you know you can do it in a number
of ways and various schools have chosen
different routes Harvard Business School
for example has chosen to set up
research centers all around the world
northwestern has chosen to do
educational programs in cooperation with
other schools what we've done so far is
really not to engage in partnerships
with other with other schools around the
world because we find that you sometimes
don't have a perfect alignment of the
agenda so so at the moment what we have
is a we have a research center in india
we have a we have a global mba program
that we run in korea and china and the
major way that we go global as through
these map projects and other global
global projects courses so i think i
personally believe it's really important
for the students to experience a
particular culture I was in India in
last December and I think just what you
can learn from intelligent observation
of what's going on is really important
so we intend to be as a platform for
more of our action based learning work
outside the United States will be
establishing more kind of small bricks
and mortar investments I don't think
it's particularly useful to be going to
another country and staying in a
classroom and just studying in that
classroom what's important i think is to
get immersed into the local economy so
whereas some schools are going global
vice via setting up executive mba
programs around the world i haven't seen
much value in that to the students who
are back at hawn on the home campus so
our strategy is much more to figure out
ways to get our full-time students who
would be enrolled in ann arbor to get
them out and have a global experience so
we'll be expanding on the map project
activity and i think to have a presence
in country to help us with the sourcing
of those projects
and to help us with admissions of
students from those countries to our
campus in Ann Arbor those are useful
investments that will be making and
expanding over the next few years
I didn't stay doing the case meds for 21
years if I didn't wasn't a proponent of
it in some ways but i think the sole
reliance on it can be can be a can be a
limitation and that's why when we would
try to figure out okay how do we really
differentiate our school it's not that
we don't do any case studies they are a
tremendous device for developing
students problem-solving skills which
are really which are really valuable but
on the other hand when you talk to
companies as I spent the majority of my
first year doing as Dean going out and
talking to companies and say look what
really distinguishes you're great people
from your from your good people it was
never well so it's always a great
problem solver it was always well so
what so is the person who is able to see
things that other people can't see and
he's also the person that when everybody
else is saying oh my gosh what are we
going to do we have nothing that will
possibly be able to do to the to solve
this issue he or she is the one was able
to say well look actually we have
through the three different things we
could do so trying to think about well
what do you how could you develop the
skills that go on the front end of a
case study that you develop students
sentient ability to make sense of the
situation and then really frame the
problem and so that's what we've tried
to do with our action based learning
projects where as we send students out
for a two-month project there is no case
we give a one page description of the
problem and many times the problem is
when you really look at it at saying
well go help this company figure out how
they could do better so we deliberately
leave the job of defining what the
issues are in providing the students the
space to really find the opportunity in
the situation so I believer that the
three fundamental ways that you can
think about education there being a
professor or upfront lecturing telling
you what he or she has inside their head
secondly some case studies in which you
are in discussion for them and also an
action based learning combining
those three in the right way is what I
think is the right way to do both mba
and BBA education
well that's I guess that's my what I
think of as my primary job and I guess
the a couple well a few a few kind of
everyday ways and a few maybe a little
bit kind of more abstract I guess
abstract ways that that I that I try to
do it but I mean in terms of trying to
create a learning community one one of
the things we try to do is create a
physical space to to accommodate a
learning community and so it our new
building what we have is it's all built
around what we call the winter garden
which is where about 450 people will be
sit seated from about gets going about
ten o'clock in the morning and it goes
till about one o'clock at night and so
that's sort of the heart and soul of our
of our community and I think the so
that's one is to have the physical
infrastructure there the second thing is
from the beginning to be telling
students about what their job is at the
school that you know our first test when
we're deciding whether to admit you to
the school or not is can you learn in
this environment so we don't do you any
favors if you don't have the analytical
skills to deal with the statistics
courses or the business economics
courses and so forth but we're fortunate
enough that we can fill the school up
ten times over with people who can learn
effectively in our environment so we get
to create a situation where we're really
choosing the students to join our
environment based upon what we think
they can teach the rest of us so the
idea of having a diverse student body in
you know gender race national origin
what kind of activities they've been
involved in in the past it really gives
us the opportunity to think not of
having 180 teachers which is how many
ten your tenure track faculty we have
but if we think of ourselves as having
three thousand teachers because that's
what our student body plus our faculty
together so I'm always try
to stress that we are a learning
community when we talked about building
our new facility it was never about
we're trying to build a great teaching
facility it was we're trying to create a
great learning facility by having 3,000
people who really have a teaching burden
for the rest of us so those would be too
I guess the third one is you're always
trying to attract people who are going
to bring ´excitement´ and intellectual
curiosity into our classrooms in our
environments and then I think the fourth
fourth thing is that you're really
trying to create something which has a
high degree of excitement to it that
were always out there pushing new
boundaries and we had our perspective
MBA students in a couple weeks ago and i
was talking to them about what i thought
was some of the different things about
the school that maybe they wouldn't see
by reading our brochures and i told them
the story about when i was i was on a
panel of three Dean's talking to new ph
DS and young faculty members were around
the country about what does a dean do
and it was you know kind of an
interesting question because faculty
typically haven't really seen it very
much up close and say that they don't
know and so the two Dean's ahead of me
spoke about well basically what we have
to do is we have to manage budgets and
we have to make sure the priorities of
the university or aligned with the
school and you know which is something
that I have to do but it's not how I
think about my job and so I so I told
them that what I said to the audience
was well how many neil young fans do we
have in the audience and there were lots
of neil young fan so i said well you
know one of neil's songs on hard gold
DVD is about going out and hunt with his
dog named king and he said he loved his
dog named King because he wasn't afraid
to jump it off the truck in high gear
and I thought well you know in some
sense that's maybe the most important
thing that a Dean can do is create an
environment in which you can take
sensible risks and and really bring so
much excitement and enter
g into the into the day-to-day life of
the school and you know I had a finance
professor come to me a couple years ago
and said I'd like to create a new course
on sustainable finance and I said well
what what is it he said well I'm not
sure he said but it's something which is
going to marry all of these concepts of
sustainability with the world of finance
and so we said yeah we'll go we'll go
make that bed and so I think it's the
idea of being willing to do some
experiments being smart enough to come
back around a couple of years later and
look at the flowers you planted and see
whether they're blooming or not but I
think to try to create a place that it's
the academic world is great in the sense
that you know the the cost of an
experiment is fairly low and so we have
to be creating a situation where we're
going to go try things that you wouldn't
be able to try other places so so I
think it's always trying to inject that
sense of excitement into the day-to-day
kind of learning activities